les canadiens sont divisés concernant
l'avenir des programmes des deux mises
en place par le gouvernement fédéral
pour faire face aux conséquences de la
coved 19 sondage réalisé par léger
l'association d'études canadiennes
révèle que 41 % voudraient qu'ottawa
réduise immédiatement ses programmes de
soutien et 44 % ne le souhaite pas
l'opinion est beaucoup plus tranchées
lorsqu'on demande aux gens s'ils sont
inquiets de l'ampleur du déficit de 340
3 milliards de dollars a révélé la
semaine dernière
soixante dix huit pour cent des
répondants sont inquiets et 18 % ne le
sont pas et afin de réduire le déficit
les répondants préfèrent clairement une
baisse des dépenses plutôt qu'une hausse
des impôts à 60 % contre 21 %
le sondage a été réalisé en ligne du 10
au 12 juillet avec 1523 répondants et on
va d'ailleurs en parler avec la
professeure line latulippe chercheur
principal à la chaire en fiscalité et
finances publiques de l'université de
sherbrooke
bonjour madame latulippe bonjour on sent
vraiment lorsqu'on regarde les résultats
l'on sent vraiment les canadiens qui
sont divisés sur la question est ce que
ça vous étonne vraiment étonnant dans la
mesure où on est dans une situation que
je m'étais véhicule
on constate vraiment un déficit inégalée
donc l'ampleur du déficit amène
nécessairement nécessairement des
craintes parce qu'on connaît pas
l'avenir on on sait pas quand est ce que
tout ça va pouvoir se résorber donc
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
peut qui peut inquiéter pour il faut
quand même mettre ce déficit en contexte
d'une part ça se compare avec ce que ce
que d'autres pays ont vécu mais
évidemment les pays en sciences compare
avec les pays qui l'ont qui ont mis en
place des mesures quand même assez assez
généreuse là pour soutenir les gens puis
d'economie de façon générale donc 1 15 %
du pib
on se compare peut-être à certains pays
qui ont aussi agi de façon très très
proactive et canada demeure un des bons
élèves également aussi le no-cd
lorsqu'on regarde la dette versus donc
le pib mais est ce que vous trouvez que
le gouvernement est allé trop loin dans
son âme
latulippe l'avenir va nous le dire
je pense qu'on peut pas en ce moment
d'hirson est allé trop loin
ce qu'on constate c'est effectivement
que le canada quand on regarde
l'ensemble des mesures des différentes
mesures qui existent le canada a mis en
place pratiquement chacune de ces
mesures là alors que certains pays ont
choisi un davantage certaines mesures
plutôt que d'autres il faut voir aussi
que certaines mesures qu'on l'a mis en
place pour pallier à une problématique
par exemple au niveau du système
d'assurance d'assurance emploi donc pour
pallier à son amie la subvention en
place il faut voir cette subvention leur
ont été mis en place
c'est le système d'assurance emploi qui
aurait plongé une partie de de ça donc
oui effectivement on a mis plusieurs
mesures en place la plupart des gens
s'entendent le directeur du bureau
parlementaire aussi de 10 du budget le
disait vaut mieux ça que rien donc on ne
peut pas ne rien faire n'était pas été
pas une option il fallait vraiment agir
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est
aussi con i dans dans différentes phases
de reprise à l'eau cdo identifié
différentes phases la première phase
c'est la réponse immédiate et sur le
canada très bien très bien mal j il
fallait s'assurer que les gens avaient
du revenu pour pour subvenir à leurs
besoins essentiels rapidement donc dans
la phase d'urgence que les entreprises
aussi avait pas de problème de liquidité
trop immédiat donc soyez très bien agi
dans cette phase là qu'ils dégageaient
des sommes évidemment importante
puis par la suite on est tombé dans une
deuxième phase assez rapidement où l'on
était dans la suède et la survie les
entreprises qui aident les ménages mais
dans quelque chose d'un petit peu plus
long terme
mais cette phase là elle reste elle doit
rester en place tant qu' on y pense
revenu à une économie plus de plus
normal c'est-à-dire à une vie un peu
plus normale
tant qu'on a des mesures de confinement
tant que la réouverture est pas
complètement reprises mais on reste dans
cette phase le plus important c'est la
location donc vous savez donc on annonce
ou cèdent entre la prolongation de la
subvention salariale
mais j'aimerais aussi qu'on regarde
madame latulippe le grand dilemme du
gouvernement maintenant qu'est ce que
devrait faire le gouvernement pour
assainir ses finances publiques
parce qu'on parle donc évidemment
ailleurs la hausse des points de vue
d'ailleurs donc dans le sondage
s'étaient pas tellement populaire serre
rejetés d'ailleurs par le gouvernement
trudeau baisse des dépenses mais ça 100
m difficile dans le contexte de pandémie
on sent que le gouvernement veut
davantage privilégier les
investissements
wii wii fit si effectivement la bonne la
bonne chose à faire
de plus en plus d'études démontrent que
de deux aussi les impôts ou de diminuer
les dépenses de couper dans les dépenses
mais ça nuit à la relance économique
donc d'aller vers l'iss d'investissement
c'est nécessairement une bonne chose
l'hiver les investissements il ya certes
un consensus quant au fait qu'un effet
direct sur sur le pib
ça va augmenter la croissance ça va
favoriser la croissance économique donc
de faire des investissements si c'est
une c'est une excellente chose une bonne
façon de relancer
maintenant il faut aussi se demander
comment faire ses réinvestissements lol
et quelques airs et investissements sont
le plus profitable
peut-être que c'est un bon moment pour
pour s'assurer aussi de bien cibler les
investissements qu'on fait s'assurer de
favoriser le développement l'innovation
s'assurer aussi que le gouvernement
soutienne soutiennent certaines
industries où certains investissements
aimé qu'il soit présent pour le la
partie des risques donc pour assurer
quelques entreprises prennent les
risques nécessaires et tout ça mais
aussi qui profitent des retombées
éventuellement donc d'avoir une vision
de l'investissement qui favorise ces
deux aspects dans cette partition sata
est également haut dans différents
projets et aussi des points
d'interrogation aussi à madame la tuer
puis on va se laisser là dessus combien
de temps va durer la pandémie on navigue
en plein brouillard s'il y avait par
exemple d'une deuxième vague une
troisième vague sur certaines
s'ajouteraient
du poil adaptée au saut du site tout à
fait tout à fait en ce moment avec le
300-350 presque 350 milliards
d'estimations du déficit on on a pris en
compte
un prolongement des mesures jusqu'en
décembre ou à cause de certaines mesures
jusqu'en décembre
donc s'il y avait une deuxième vague à
l'automne indépendamment de l'ampleur
que ça prend dépendamment des mesures de
confinement qui doivent être mises en
place ou pas ça se pourrait que ça
augmente encore sauf que on va être
encore dans cette deuxième phase là où
la plupart des économistes s'entendent
pilot c'est dieu dit que dans cette
phase là on doit continuer à soutenir
les programmes pour intéresser alors
assurément aussi donc l'avenir nous dira
ce que pourra faire le gouvernement pour
aider aussi donc l'économie canadienne
alors merci beaucoup la tulipe chercheur
principal à la chair of skate et
finances publiques universités de
sherbrooke revoir